this is another live stream exclusive
coming at you
I was gonna say some some real like CIS
things but I'll keep it like that how
y'all doing today
bro I gotta stay on who got the energy
considering it's like midnight where he
is yeah yo I do have the energy today
it's because I haven't been able I
haven't been able to walk
for a few days so you mean walk for a
few days what's going on
um
just make do all that's all I'm gonna
say thank you
that we are in the live guys it is 607
p.m on a beautiful Wednesday don't think
this is pre-recorded come on now
um let's uh Rami got the chats and uh
the the live chat on the screen
all right guys before we begin today I
just want to give a quick shout out to
brother Yusuf arakat also known as
Fouseytube
a couple recent videos that he's been uh
sharing and other interviews and you
know
streams that I've seen of him but
without further Ado I do want Rami to
play uh the first clip in uh in a moment
but guys smash that like button we got
211 viewers mashallah we should have at
least 600 likes what are you doing come
on smash that like button around me bro
is there anything you want to say before
we jump right in no let's just go for it
all right Bismillah put up the first
clip then all right Bismillah
you know I pray every day for Allah to
take away my anxiety take away my
depression take away my fear and I'm
I've never felt better in my entire life
I've kicked all antidepressant
medications out of my life I don't touch
weed I don't touch alcohol I don't
fornicate I don't mess I don't I don't
take anything like I'm so far off life
right now it's time to land I'm feeling
better than I ever could
I'm good
all right
all right all right all right so let me
quickly close this stream right now
so for a lot of the brothers and sisters
that are tuned in right now wondering
who is that brother with all that nude
on his face mashallah on the screen
right now
um y'all heard Fouseytube Yusuf you know
who is this guy so quick little
introduction to people that don't even
know who fusi took Buzz or is right he's
a YouTuber right he started YouTube long
ago
um around the time that YouTube wasn't
even popping that much right I don't
know if ano have you watched [ __ ] 2
before he was popular or not really in
the way back in the day yeah bro he used
to make those like videos like doing uh
you remember that song Friday by Rebecca
Black he did like an Apple store and he
did a little cringy stuff like that just
to get views but then he started making
videos like living in a middle eastern
family or growing up in a middle eastern
household and that those videos really
popped off his channel because it had
that element of relatability bro that a
lot of people didn't have growing up at
least for the Muslims you know on
YouTube it wasn't really that much of a
thing so believe it or not he started
making videos like that went from I
believe four or five k subscribers to
like 100k within a few days bro once he
started making those videos so he really
did go viral and he kind of peaked out
about you know a couple mil Subs he was
making 200k per month from YouTube bro
so this guy was in terms of Dunya in
terms of imperialism mashallah he was
consumed bro he was in it and he said in
a lot of videos you know sometimes he
got a little bit lost in the sauce got
caught up with XYZ you know how it is
bro it's not too easy to you know
withstand The Temptations of the don't
even know so it's only natural some of
us straight but male got us back and
recently he's been he's been kind of you
know back on Dean as they say you know
unapologetically Muslim and I've been
liking some of the things that he's
saying so what do you guys think about
that before we play the next clip
in this beautiful world
yeah
yeah alhamdulillah I mean it's it's
about time Insha'Allah and I think
there's a few people trying to uh like
kind of clown on him for it Muslims as
well which is very very sad I think it's
pathetic of these Muslims bro like the
brother mashallah he's having like his
Redemption Arc he's coming back to Islam
and like there are people who claim to
be Muslim like trying to push him away
bro well that's disgusting so I'm very
proud of the brother may Allah bless him
yeah yeah I was just gonna say real
quick bro a lot of people like and and
here's the thing I know we're not here
trying to say you know it's Justified or
it's it's whatever but you know as
Muslims as human beings bro we're all
Sinners it's it's not something new it's
not a New Concept it's this false party
that everyone's perfect norms may Allah
is perfect right so we all sin inshallah
we can all come back to the straight
path but when we do a lot of people act
like you know tawba isn't a thing bro
you know seeking for forgiveness
repentance that's not a thing that you
can't come back to Allah and these
people make it very difficult so you
know it's times like this where we
understand that you know we might not be
perfect most of us aren't all of us
aren't and when we do want to come back
you know it's between us and Allah
doesn't matter what the people say you
know because yoga I was telling a
brother Dom on the on the other you know
stream that we did w thumbnail young
dumb I know you all fell for the
clickbait but uh when we did that uh I
was telling him bro I was like you got a
lot of tattoos you're gonna pull up in
the Masjid you know they might look at
you they might think you know
um what is this guy doing in a Masjid
with tattoos they might not know your
Reaver bro and even if they do maybe
they'll still give you some looks so
just stay strong and and don't really
let the negativity into your head
but you know what was most beautiful
it's kind of like y'all were telling me
that
I don't know if you're gonna play the
clip or not I mean where he says that he
didn't what kind of pulled him away okay
okay I don't know if I shouldn't
probably hold off and go ahead please
what pulled him away I don't think he
talked about it in the clip yeah okay so
y'all were telling me that um
he said that it wasn't Islam that pulled
him away from it because Islam is
perfect he said it was the Muslims like
the imperfect people that pulled them
away from that now why did they put them
away or the things that averted him that
I'm not too sure of but what I would say
is that like
it kind of goes back to the live stream
we made where we were kind of talking
about imongassi I don't know the Bless
America but we were saying like it's
it's a private Journey it's a private
journey and like there there will be
aspects of it that are more uh public
that are more uh shared with people and
stuff like that but for the most part
like think about it when you are
performing most of your Salas when you
are making your Dua when you are like
reaching out to Allah like are you with
other people most of the time or are you
primarily just doing it you with Allah
like it's you and Allah always it's you
and Allah so I was like I think that's
beautiful and I think for him right now
that he's letting go of all these things
and he's feeling the way he's feeling
like mashallah is beautiful and
um
he should continue down that uh private
experience with him and the Creator and
allow that to just bring him closer to
Islam you know and and it's a shame it's
just a shame that it had to be this way
with many Muslims yeah it does wrong and
and that's the thing I remember watching
this video you all know One path Network
yeah the channel yeah
well I bless those Brothers bro I'm
doing it in the East Far East bro uh
more East than Asia and uh there's one
of the brothers I forgot his name but he
has his own channel I believe it's
called Talk Islam you know I think he
has like 700k subs or something martial
is doing his thing he's closing on a
million inshallah you guys can succeed
that and go well past that very soon
inshallah but you got brother Fouseytube
uh I don't know if you guys know this
but that brother from One path he made a
video lately saying that when he started
YouTube long ago right he made this
video it was a little cringe you know he
was saying that you know it was old
maybe he was a little too aggressive but
he used to do spoken word you know and
it was about Islam and of course at that
time you know I'm not going to mention
what time it was of course it was like
almost 20 years ago 10 15 years ago the
image that was portrayed about Muslims
was not right and it still isn't right
right but whatever it was back then you
know anyone speaking good about Islam
would get shunned you know just like
today not much has changed but it was
still a different climate back then
there weren't many YouTubers like there
is today so he made a video and it got
like you know 10 views 20 views he
mentioned he was going to people trying
to get them to share it and what
happened was overnight that video got
like 100k views or something like that
and then it started oh this is the
brother from One path by the way and he
said you know
um he took a a leap of faith because he
was an introverted guy made a YouTube
got no Roi and then the video just goes
viral so he kept you know obsessively
trying to find out where did this video
come from like why did it why is it
going viral you know where did all this
traffic come from and lo and behold he
found out that brother Yusuf Fouseytube
shared that video
not take the video down uh Yusuf had to
take that share down because he was
getting a lot of backlash at the time
and why are you standing up for you know
Muslims and all this probably but
you know
you guys know we've been in the YouTube
game for just over a year now how
important it is to get you know people
to to share and support you right at
least in the earlier stages so when he
got all that traffic who knows maybe
talk Islam One path Network might not be
exactly where it is without you know
further use of facilitating that growth
we know everything's done by the
permission of Allah we know Allah is the
King of Everything but in terms of that
actual facilitator who shared that and
Allah using him as a piece of that it
might not have been the same bro perhaps
if brother
so he came out with that story recently
and and I think it's it's admirable that
he did that bro
and then I'm not someone yeah man that's
that's beautiful that literally is
beautiful may Allah bless Yusuf and the
brother from One path
but um
I think I think that inshallah fusi
needs to be surrounded by a lot more
Muslims
uh you know why do you say that because
Annie It's hard I mean look at what you
just mentioned he got a lot of slack for
defending Islam obviously his
surroundings were not very Islamic
especially at that time that's why I had
to take that video down but the more you
surround yourself with Muslims people
who are like-minded people who are
practicing people will look at you on
this journey and say mashallah that's
amazing keep going give you that you
know motivation yeah he needs that and
there's I think there's two main things
that really bring someone to Islam one
would be the community
backing them and encouraging them two
would be a hard difficult test from
Allah that really pushes you back yeah
and I think he's probably had his fair
share of those that pushed him back to
it you know like okay I need to get my
my Islamic religious stuff together now
you know maybe he realized one day I'm
gonna die maybe he went through
something difficult he's like yeah man I
need to I need to get back on this and
Allah right but I think while he's in
this stage we need Muslims to back him
up so I think inshallah'd be nice to get
him on the podcast have a nice
conversation with them record it not
recorded whatever it doesn't really
matter to be honest but I think he needs
a lot of that inshallah and we're here
for him we're here to support him
inshaallah
[Music]
but with that being said in all realness
before we go on to the next clip for the
use of if for some reason you are
watching this video we welcome you
um to study Islam learn Islam have a
conversation with us and always here bro
on or off camera especially off camera
why don't you play your equipment all
right
yogurt
by the way I guess I have to share my
screen for you guys to see it isn't that
right
all right I'm feeling great
alhamdulillah I'm feeling real good
now you looked
be focused in there
it's too much was that deliberate
I mean this entire this entire Camp
everything has been a chess move the
stuff we show whether it be good whether
it be bad it's all deliberate so they've
seen enough I don't need to show you
know night of the fight they'll see what
they need to see alhamdulillah your
weight loss Journey's been amazing for
you to see it you know I mean it's very
inspiring obviously physically you're
looking in great shape you know no one
can say nothing about that how you
feeling mentally going into this fight
alhamdulillah you know I pray every day
for Allah to take away my anxiety take
away my depression take away my fear and
I'm I've never felt better in my entire
life I've kicked all antidepressant
medications out of my life I don't touch
weed I don't touch alcohol I don't
fornicate I don't Mass I don't I don't
take anything like I'm sober off life
right now alhamdulillah I'm feeling
better than I ever could it's amazing to
him amazing to hear
are we just kind of chilling can you not
see the screen
I mean I see someone but like that I
hear nothing oh it's just a glitch on
Discord
true okay yeah so I'm just gonna I'll
finish it for the viewers and I'll kind
of elaborate if I can help as well on
what was said
I I
I'm expecting chaos I mean what am I
what am I supposed to expect I'm going
in there to get cheered I ain't going in
there to you know people excited to see
me they think they're not excited
that hate it comes from a deep rooted
love so I'm gonna put on a show for them
yeah promise the clip done
Rami I can't even hear you bro no it's
still playing and the stream can hear
you guys
I have to you know give me and put on a
hell of a show is this a make or break
fight for you
from me in my career I've been through
too much I've been through real life
circumstantial else I fought my own
demons so a YouTube boxing match at the
end of the day is it gonna make or break
me definitely not if something was gonna
make or break me would have broke me a
long time ago nothing in this life can
break me I'm with this beefy I'm going
with deji is it beef you is it just
business what is your relationship with
Digi you know I know it's probably still
playing
but I like these strings and it makes me
feel like this
I think the beef is probably one-sided
everything that he sees in me yeah
everything he doesn't see in himself
it could be a one-sided beef in that way
prediction for Saturday night how that
fight's gonna go uh prediction Saturday
night you know
my hand is raised in the air my hand is
raised in the air uh if you do God
willing win this fight do you have
anyone in mind you want to call out
right now I gotta focus on my opponent
Saturday night which is deji so after
that then we can then we can get into
those legit
all right masha'allah
I feel like we're about to play video
games right now or something bro what
makes you say that I know I don't know
it really feels like we're about to play
video games like we're about to stream
on video games that would be sick Bro yo
t3n we should start that you know
someone on the second Channel bro
someone who claimed to work like they
they say that they need to work at track
they commented on my video recently
someone who claims to work or he says he
used to work for Treyarch he commented
on my stream last night and uh he's like
you know we can we can get together and
like try and do something for the
Muslims and gaming and stuff so
all right so what are your thoughts on
the video Rami do you want to quickly
reiterate and by the way
um huge shout-out for the background
commentary on the video
um he didn't want all the focus on the
video so he used his uh voice down there
love that I couldn't hear nothing so I
thought it was a dead quiet I was like
let me let me talk a little bit uh it's
not a good broadcast why don't you uh do
you want to summarize what happened
around me yeah so it was it was actually
a longer clip of the first clip he was
uh basically being interviewed before
the fight about the fight and they were
asking general questions for example you
know is this fight gonna make or break
you he said he's been through things in
life that you know if he was going to be
broken those things would have broken
him a lot a long time ago and that this
fight is kind of just like is another
thing in his life he also mentioned that
he's off of certain you know uh drugs
certain drinks certain you know things
that people usually use to kind of
Escape life no medication all that stuff
he said he's sober just living life now
alhamdulillah and he seems to be really
really transformed He also mentioned I
know one of the interviewers was Muslim
but he also mentioned that you know uh
Allah he said that exactly you know and
I think that's really big for
alhamdulillah to be able to use Muslim
you know terminology and Islamic
terminology and Arabic words like that
in an interview where he knows most
people are not going to understand what
he's saying they might be intrigued and
go and look it up and look into Islam I
think that's powerful
um
I think they're so
I'm not going to say dumb because it's
just it's how it is like when you're in
the the sports or just like in the the
hype scene you know like a really
publicized thing but it's like
make or break you like really like this
fight gonna make or break him like
in front of the entire world and have it
be recorded yeah like whether he
wouldn't have lost a fight like it's
it's there forever yeah for the most
part you know like not many people can
say that they would do or not maybe we
can actually do that some people will
say this they would be like oh no I do
it I do it but when it's like the moment
came down to it they probably wouldn't
do it you know
it was like Make It or Break It that
doesn't make any sense I mean like he
already had the balls to go out there
and do it and then like he said you know
he's already been through so many things
like oh he has his YouTube channel that
he's had for years I'm talking about
years like
Big Time news right and he's been like
putting out like a lot of I'd say a lot
of private stuff as well you know like
if you've actually paid attention to
some of the stuff he's posted he's put a
lot of private stuff out there like one
of the things he was talking about the
um he did the SMP treatment for his head
it's um there's a lot of people if you
don't know what that is SMP is a scalp
micropigmentation it's like a tattoo not
really a tattoo but it's supposed to be
like if you're bald it gives you the
illusion as if you had a shaved head
um so what it does mostly is frames your
face some people like this some people
don't like it this man he did it he
ended up doing it and he actually had a
bad experience with it and he documented
that like he he showed people what it
was like getting this experience and
then you know getting it undone and
getting a different you know treatment
and all this stuff so it's like come on
bro like he said it best if if something
would have been like Make It or Break It
would have been something
much different than just going on a
fight and whether winning or losing I
don't even know what the outcome was of
the fight by the way
notes box he did lose bro he lost to
deji
is
uh I've heard someone say in the video
he's he's ksi's younger brother yeah
yeah he is I don't know he's actually
his biological blood brother he is
actually black Brothers yeah
um KSI gave a huge shout out multiple
tweets to uh fusi for thinking like a
champ and uh you know putting his
purpose and and God and all that first
so huge shout out to them and uh I did
want to say and touch on the point that
that brother Yusuf was saying you know
there's times in our life well maybe he
didn't say this but the main point that
he was saying is you know I'm not on
these things anymore all these
antidepressants I don't smoke weed I
don't drink alcohol I don't you know
have you know promiscuity and and
immorality in terms of that and I feel
better than I've ever done I pray every
day and I wanted to touch on that point
bro that you know some people they have
to learn the hard way they have to go
against what is mentioned not that they
should but they learn the hard way
um or you can learn the easy way of just
you know under standing that these
things are forbidden and prohibited for
a reason now it's not so easy because
some people think that the grass is
greener on the other side even though we
know it's not right so Rami what would
you say to that because a lot of people
say you know what good experience comes
from you know wisdom but wisdom comes
from bad experience so what do you think
about that
uh wisdom doesn't only come from bad
experience wisdom comes from wherever
you know you can get it from and for
example if if you had a book you know
it's going to sound very familiar if you
had a book that told you to avoid
certain things that book could be very
wise whether you understand it or not
you know kind of like the Quran kind of
like the son of the Prophet peace upon
him so Allah is the most wise and he's
uh I think is the most knowledgeable he
knows everything
and he has Infinite Wisdom yeah so if he
gives I'm going to stop saying yeah
so if he gives you a book and a
messenger with the perfect way to live
the most wise thing you could do is just
live by that book
so if these people saying that and when
you say grass is greener on the other
side do you mean of like of like things
that are prohibited
yeah like they think you know pleasures
and temporary delusions they think oh my
God it must be like all of that
well I mean they say that until they do
it 20 30 times and then it becomes stale
and they're on to the next thing so it's
just instant gratification at least
nowhere long term it makes them actually
depressed if anything long term so
wisdom comes from the Quran if you want
to be wise just remember this follow the
Quran Sunnah you will be
um you'll be chill you'll be fine avoid
what is Haram do what is foreign things
that are of benefit to you and it's as
easy as that if you're one of those
persons or one sorry one of those people
that are like you know let me just try I
just want to see what it feels like your
grass is greener on this side because as
soon as you try it you know what it
feels like you might fall into an
addiction you might fall into the state
of I want it again oh I need it I need
it and let me keep doing it and keep
doing it and then becomes an addiction
and it becomes dangerous and it becomes
uh damaging to you psychologically
spiritually physically and um you know
the grass is dying on that side but you
don't know that
until you get there so avoid it at all
costs if you want
you know a high or whatever there are
other ways to get high not like
literally high like you know
delusionally high but an adrenaline High
to have fun you know to have a good time
there are many highlighted ways to do
this you don't have to smoke you don't
have to drink you don't have to do these
things to have fun to have a good time
and actually if anything that's just a
cop-out an avoidance of actually having
fun you want to feel like you're having
fun without actually doing anything bro
just go I don't know go on a hike with
friends go play some basketball play
soccer work out in many ways to have fun
man
let me let me tell you something a point
that you mentioned and I got this from
you bro because you said in another
podcast but the urge and craving and
desire that you feel right now without
doing it is not going to be as strong as
you will after you do it the first time
just trust me it's a slippery slope it's
not worth it yeah that is done any
thoughts or do you want to you know we
can go to the third clip I mean just
think about what I've said multiple
times in the past my mind stretched by a
new experience can never go back to its
old dimensions
so you might have a urge of craving to
get high or experience this thing but if
you've never experienced it like
it's not gonna be the same as when you
actually do it once you actually do it
like it kind of just did Yourself dirty
now you just kind of like hooked
yourself in
you know it's like if you take a person
who's never watched pornography a day in
his life
and then you put them next to the person
who they ended up watching pornography
and you tell them don't watch
pornography
the guy who's never watched pornography
things like he's not gonna know what it
is he's not gonna know what it feels
like so it's not going to be that it's
not going to be an issue at all for this
man because the guy that that's had
pornography that's seen pornography
don't watch pornography and it's like he
starts tweaking he starts like a
crackhead like having withdrawal
symptoms and all this stuff so it just
goes to show like look
there's some things I just better left
unexperienced
untouched
as if you know what I mean
a thousand percent
all right very beautiful Chad let's go
on to the third clip it's gonna be about
about two minutes
starting now
you've told everyone to pronounce you by
your first full name now so I'll let you
introduce yourself again my name is
Yusuf salad
what what's the what's the reason for
the chin why do you want people to know
you by your real name now you know a lot
of people knew me for a persona for all
the years you know they I built a person
on the internet somebody who was outside
of myself but going to bed at night is
Yusuf and then turning on the camera and
being this character that I don't even
you know agree with a lot of the things
he did a lot of the things he said I
think I'm at the age and the time in my
life where I want to be known as my
birth name and be the person I'm
intended to be on and off the camera
respect you for that we got suggested at
the Wayne most people go viral for doing
a media workout in public but your video
of you praying went viral I just want
you to let the fans know you know what
you were saying if you could translate
it to them uh I read the Surah fatah
it's the opening Surah in the Quran
um and you know from a young age my
mother always told me whenever I was
stressed anxious nervous needed
protection whatever to revert back
what was in my heart and it was through
the fact that
at the media workout which is give my
faith to God let them know that no
matter all this training that I did
without him it doesn't matter
definitely man and you mentioned your
nose injury are you concerned at all
that could go again in the fight no
straightforward man and what kind of
fight you expected from Digi obviously
he's not going to win to his record but
he's had three fights will it make a
difference he's had two more fights than
you no I think
um
it's going to be two men who come in who
are confident one is just going to be
more confident than the other and one is
going to get a soul taken away a little
by little
Topman uh last message Yusuf
message to your fans
hope you enjoyed the show everybody hope
you enjoyed the show thanks for the
all right so
long story short a few of the things he
talked about another interview the
interviewer asked him about him using
his personal name rather than Fouseytube
he asked why his name is Yusuf actually
so inshallah maybe you know we should
just call him that instead but
uh he says he doesn't agree with a lot
of the things he did as fousey as this
other persona a lot of things he said
and did and he just wants to kind of you
know be himself so he's like call me
Yusuf I'm Yusuf I think that's a very
beautiful thing inshallah especially
because Yusuf is a name you know one of
the prophets in the Quran this entire
Surah beginning to end all dedicated
just the story to the story of yusufraid
and then um
He also mentioned that uh basically the
prayer that he recited was Fatiha
you know the first Surah in the Quran
and um some of the teachings that his
mom gave him at a young age islamically
always read it when you're stressed or
nervous and so on and so forth so it's
very beautiful bro to see this come out
you know it's
it's it's the same thing online with
people you know money girls blah blah
blah bro like
get a life man come on like are you that
spiritually dead that all these things
make up your life these things alone
materialism women pleasure that's your
entire life physical pleasure
getting your your wee-wee hard is that
literally all you live for man come on
SO to see this from the brother
mashallah it's so beautiful man honestly
I think inshaallah it'll be refreshing
for a lot of people but what do you guys
think based on what I said you didn't
see the clip
it's a it's a river story yeah yeah yeah
like we always say rivets is like people
like myself who
you know they weren't Muslim before but
no man it's like I told y'all
even born Muslims like y'all revert as
well because there comes a time where
you're no longer Muslim by by mouth by
name but you're Muslim by heart
like that's the reversion that's the
real reverse story
I'm like if I had it Romney had
I had
all the Muslims that you see that are
like proper like on being like they all
had that reboot story they all had the
moment where it's like boom like they
just it came in the heart and
mashallah man like it's beautiful to see
that it's it's happening for the brother
Yusuf
um
five bro how about you
I like the point where he mentioned that
you know I used to be named Fouseytube
and everyone has the reasons why they
don't want to come across with their
real name or or a pure Muslim you know
maybe they're afraid maybe they're shy
maybe they don't want to be associated
with the way Islam is portrayed by the
media whatever the reason may be maybe
maybe they don't want to lose Subs you
name it but the fact that he admitted
today you know my name is Yusuf this is
what I want to be known as not the old
me not fousey
that that old me has done things that I
don't agree with right now present day
it shows that at least it's never too
late and he took that step to be
authentic even if it's you know better
late than never yeah and it's better
than you know to continue living life
once you find yourself once you know the
truth like whether Antoine was saying
that a lot of the reavers did it's
better to like find the truth and then
accept it despite all the reasons you
have of not accepting it that you made
up despite how late you might think you
are to the party
instead of just like continuing it and
living in that delusion role continuing
to be like you know what I don't want to
tell people my name is Yusuf it's okay
nah bro like enough is enough and he's
man enough to say it yeah it reminds me
of uh
when I had changed my YouTube channel
name which is a big move
which cost me a lot of uh
and my my channel was like up and rising
and it actually I think it actually cut
that rise off
for me to like come in and say like look
this is my real name this is what I want
y'all to recognize me as not this like
old Channel like facade that I had
before this is me and this is what it's
going to be from now on and like from
there on again like I'm not trying to
bring it to me but I'm just saying like
uh you get to the point where you you
kind of just want to be real you kind of
just want to be real to not to the world
but to yourself and how can you be real
to yourself if you're portraying
something that you're not
yeah that's very true very true this
reminds me of um an Ayah in the Quran I
don't have the full I am memorized but
uh something along the lines of uh
amongst the men
um the believing men are those who
foreign
they like basically they held true to
the word with Allah
and then others who have yet to so you
know think about the person who comes to
realization you know man I'm at a low
point or I haven't been practicing I
need to get back on it and maybe even
they say Allah I'm going to come back to
your religion you know I'm here I'm a
Muslim alhamdulillah
they say it they mean it
and then you know a monk from amongst
the people that do that there's those
who actually hold true to that Covenant
that promise with Allah and others who
have yet to others who kind of maybe
straight back and they actually haven't
started to fulfill that promise to Allah
or hold it up and then Allah talks about
it's up to Allah whether he forgives
them and brings them to Mercy or if he
punishes them subhanallah and I think
it's really prevalent here because you
know we're talking about Yusuf but he's
not the only one Yusuf is just one
person he has to follow me Allah bless
them and grant them success in this life
in the next Allah I mean but there are
many people who are in his exact
situation but their life isn't being
documented because they don't have a
fight that you know thousands and
millions of people are going to watch
so I think insha Allah Yusuf can
definitely be a beautiful example for
young Brothers out there to come to
their Deen to come to the religion of
Allah and like you mentioned if I'd be
unapologetically Muslim you don't have
to apologize for your faith even in
their secular liberal Society they let
you practice so they're gonna end their
own liberal Society let you practice and
then contradict themselves by mocking
you for your practice bro
they're never gonna be happy until you
abandon your religion so just practice
bro we don't need to make these people
happy let them hate us let them be mad
bro who cares I'm sorry but who cares
really we want to make Allah happy and
if Allah is happy and they hate us bro
who cares we've succeeded and if they
love us and Allah is not you know Allah
doesn't love us he's not pleased with us
or he dislikes us bro failure of the
utmost stature
um I want to take this time quickly to
thank Brother Ali chabar for the Super
Chat for the 45 bucks he says shabab
keep it up going to show an email later
inshallah we will definitely be on the
lookout for that and brother bucker for
the Super Chat thank you happy may Allah
bless you
so I mean I mean I'm in Europe
also if you guys see me like rubbing my
neck bro if I knows all about this I got
like a pinched nerve this morning when I
woke up the most painful thing my neck
has ever experienced man and uh that's
why so I might use this towel later
don't think I'm a weirdo right it's just
for the well-being of my neck
[Laughter]
hold you bro you gotta start working
your neck up I told him bro
inshallah
anything I want to say uh no I think I
talked a lot already bro on Humber what
about you I don't know anything before
we wrap it up
now there's a rabbit
throw it up boy all right guys if you
made it this far smash that like button
share this video and tag Lucy sends to
foosi however you can Yusuf bro come on
now if you made it this far you know
what time it is get on this podcast and
show Allah or have a talk with us
without without cameras either way bro
we want to know about your stories in a
man booster for us and um amen
all right and with that being said